Dr. Connors.
Yes, sir.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
This is Steve.
And just curious, I've been to trying the life one protocol
along with everything else.
And it's just a lot of healthy supplements, of course,
as you probably know.
But one of the things that says in order
to allow it to help you more because I've had chemo,
it says to take a D-aramutase or some sort
of estrogen blocker of sorts.
I'm just curious what your thoughts are about that.
So estrogen blockers, you're talking about, like,
DNA and things like that.
Natural estrogen blockers.
Yes, that's correct.
OK, so a lot of people think that those are only for women.
And that is a huge bit.
We are all exposed to exogenous estrogen.
So that's estrogen for our environment.
Better exposed to just as many as women.
So just because women make more estrogen in their body
than men do, men still make estrogen.
But it isn't the estrogen that you make in your body.
That is the problem.
It's the exogenous estrogen.
The estrogen that you get from the environment.
So men eat dim almost as much as women eat dim.
Now, dim is just one thing that can help block bad estrogens.
Look on our blog under aroma taste
to start typing aroma taste.
And you'll see multiple blog posts aroma taste
in hematers.
So aroma taste is an enzyme that's made in all your cells.
And it's more potent in your fat cells.
Your fat cells are the cells that store hormones.
So if I have excess hormones today,
they can either get dumped into my colon
and be exited into the toilet,
or they'll be stored in my fat cells.
And then they will aromatize through the process
of an enzyme called aromatase into hormones.
They'll be they can aromatize into different metabolites
of testosterone and estrogen.
And that can cause problems.
So there are so if anybody here has done the Dutch test
or the Dutch test is a dried urine hormone test,
it's the most accurate hormone test.
If anybody here has done that,
you'll see that you have a lot of different metabolites
of your hormones.
You don't just have testosterone in estrogen and progesterone.
You have all these under metabolites.
This can metabolite is A converts to B, converts to C, converts to D.
And D is really the most utilized form of estrogen, right?
So you have esterone and hydroxyestero
and two hydroxyestero and four hydroxyestero
and 16 hydroxyestero.
And it's the four hydroxyestero and pathway
that can be very damaging and be a major player in cancers.
So how do you get rid of those?
Well, you get rid of those naturally through pathways.
But the problem is is that we have so much extra estrogen
that we're exposed to that we get in abundance
of four hydroxyestero.
And that can be very damaging to ourselves.
Even if you do not have an estrogen receptor positive cancer
or a hurt to positive cancer,
it can still be a player and a cancer.
So I'm very careful not to give people way too many supplements.
But you've got to consider at some point
that maybe taking something to help with that
with polito, bad estrogen's will would be a good idea.
And we have a new product called a Roman clear.
And it's meant to be a play on a Roman taste.
We have to be so careful how we name supplements.
That's a private label supplement.
And I believe it has calcium debuterated it and it's dimmed it
as something else that I can't think of enough to top my head.
That is going to be one of my new favorite supplements
to use for polito, bad estrogen.
So look into that.
So I know a lot of people are like,
I'm tired of taking supplements.
I don't want to take any more supplements.
I'm not saying that everybody needs to take that.
But that can be a good player at some people's point.